vous écouter une chanson sur un jeu
extrêmement particulier c'est un petit
jeu dans lequel on va devoir choisir qui
tue et je sais c'est bizarre ou d'un
docteur qui remplace un ancien docteur
pendant notre emplacement de choisir
quel patient a des problèmes
psychiatriques
mais en fait si un patient qui contamine
les autres patients et c'est celui-là
qu'on a trouvé égorgé sa mère pardonnez
moi je garde mon calme chez un docteur
très serein vous en faites pas moi je
vois des rhinopharyngites et des angines
tous les jours pour choisir quelle
passion doigt mouillé vous avez accès
aux notes de l'ancien docteur vous avez
trois caméras sur lesquels tu peux voir
les différents patients et les fait
réagir à différentes choses
j'espère que tu feras un bon travail
j'espère que vous allez faire mon
travail si tu trouves un pistolet ne
t'en fais pas l'ancien docteur a vidé
les balles pour des raisons de sécurité
presse action to continue c'est parti
alors effectivement on a juste là le
panneau sur lequel on peut voir le
patient pas sur deux patientes 3 et le
gardien aussi que d'importants bardon ok
et donc ça c'est le labo de l'ancien
docteur où il ya des notes donc là on
voit les trois mois j'avais que c'est
lui en revue les bulls ont regardé avec
celui-ci
après vous avez quoi est ce que tu te
rends tu laisses patients with le but
j'ai fait le mauvais choix à zut
suivez moi c'est vrai que des fois je
fais des mauvais pronostic mais c'est
assez rare
ok ok aquanautes ici à trois fois avec
remarqué dessus des cigarettes puisque
le mec s'ennuie dans son labo et là il
ya un truc la dangereuse infection
marche seulement jour un d'accord
décembre l'aïe note jonathan choqué ce
qu'elle dit on dirait que la musique
calme infecte les patients je pense ma
traduction est pas très correct mais
hélas le fameux pistolet vide qu'on fait
ce labo sert à rien l'ancien docteur on
comprend pourquoi il est parti au
chômage il était nul alors c'est parti
aurait commencé à analyser ces gens dont
déjà quand j'en vois aucun signal qui se
passe
lui il est là il regarde ses mains et a
l'air normal à quoi qu'il allait un peu
stressé 1 c'est bizarre mais ça seul sa
femme l'a quitté son enfant a raté son
bac ou là ou là il s'y tient manière pas
naturel auquel 2 qu'est ce qui se passe
sur le 2 il caresse son matelas c'est
lui es tu un peu extrême tendance que je
discutais mois dans l'ue est là c'est
normal il est posé tranquillou élu haut
la ola là il va pas bien lui le patient
trois là qu'est ce qui se passe avec cet
homme une camisole déjà de base ok alors
c'est parti enjouaillez de la musique
calme pour voir ce qui se passe
réduit il kiffe tranquillement
oh la la il allait à fond dans son truc
lui il danse à lesquin d'invisibles
auxquelles lula il a un truc chelou
l'aele dernière le dernier il est
tranquille du limbourg god oh là où il
est par lui réagit bien lu à la musique
là un sdf carrément et il sera soit
d'accord attend c'est dur de trouver
bourgain d'envoi des enquêtes enquête
criminelle est totalement nulle à chier
à tanger aurait en revanche j'aimerais
revoir lui il a l'air trop posséder un
c'est bizarre on déclarait que il vit la
musique qu'il est sur la vague sur la
vague twilight ce qui vient de faire
injure à j'invente rien ne lui sont pas
les sacs d'accord ok ok qu'est ce qu'on
va faire d'autres maîtres de la musique
violente
oui envoyé du gaz excitant à tanger
carrément faire ça qu'est ce qui se
passe quand votre case excitant pas aux
mollahs legrand d'année n'est pas
content le premier holla holla île
bizard lui en lui je trouve revanche
loin son décodeur luis ferreira le gaz
excitant avec talent d'or il est
beaucoup trop résistants mais quand il
se fait opérer il est dans la merde y'a
aucune anesthésie qui barrent choix sa
luxueuse vite fait il se met debout quoi
ouais cédule il fait quoi il va sous le
lit à lui qui compulse [ __ ] le gardien
attention je peux envoyer le garder à
voir les mecs
d'accord il va voir le troisième mois a
alors holla holla c'est quoi ce gardien
google est en train de péter un câble
calme toi j'étais juste demandé d'aller
voir dans la chambre
3 allée b qui arrache quitte qu'est ce
que c'est qu'est ce qui lui prend
maintenant oui calme-toi la glace faible
un fauteuil qui raconte à tous c'est
scandaleux
attention le pire garde-temps dit oui le
barça solo ça docteur il est pas parti
c'est fait buter par le gardien moi je
pense musique violente qu'est ce qui se
passe aux usa bouche les oreilles il va
tranquille lui il a un peu fâché ouais
il en a un peu marre baissa pas celui-là
bien web et lui là dans le rock d'accord
donc a vraiment aucune réaction de la
part de la musique violente mais moi je
dirais que c'est lui c'est lui qui a le
moins de réactions la musique violente
voyez aulas il se frotte la calvitie
uniquement la calvitie est là on la
connaît bien les gars après est-ce que
je me trouve baby attend c'est génial ce
jeu là on our 14 hockey jusqu'à luiz cap
tout jab sur le bouton calme ah ouais
d'accord ok lui s'endort lui fait de
position foetale et lui bon lui ça
changerait rien comme ça dans les
grandes années google est vraiment vos
asperges buts à ses tirs
j'ai tellement envie de vous prouver que
je suis un super inspecteurs que j'ai
beaucoup talent là dedans on quoi
écouter je m'assois sur ce fauteuil avec
ce petit whisky et les glaçons je vais
prendre une décision
on va recoller les morceaux rap art
jackson cette fracture cache le mot
calme alors pourquoi l'avoir remarqué à
droite entre guillemets pourquoi parler
de la musique calme mais pour parler du
bouton calme voyez tout commence à
celui-ci des jackson 3 feuilles non pas
de nos packs à trois feuilles parce
qu'il ya une faille par passion
effectivement vers de la gauche vers la
droite passe au numéro en face au numéro
3 la feuille tout à gauche et dans
l'obscurité un autre exemple où
l'infection l'homme qui va mal cette
feuille nous et donc sur la piste du
patient numéro un qui est infecté mais
on ne peut pas juger si facile mort
quand j'appuie sur le bouton calme et il
n'y a aucune réaction spécifique de
chacun un sms d'inspecteurs coordonne la
musique violente quand elle n'intéresse
pas nos sujets ci contre en revanche
s'il va nous intéresser si le bouton
calme marquée 6 contre je suppose qu'une
réaction est à remarquer le grand dan et
autres maps les asperges s'endort cet
homme-là sonore aussi cet homme là a des
convulsions des véritables spasmes n'est
pas normal cet homme veut avoir de gros
problèmes aux puces oiseaux qu'elles
sont achetés précédemment monoprix est
maintenant temps de prendre une décision
le patient numéro un j'espère pas tuer
d'innocents on a fait le bon choix de
son des platines au sort oui la flèche
d'or de la boxe à vélo sur ce jeu hyper
particulier en jeu près tout ça vous a
plu mais en tout cas ça m'a fait kiffer
le temps de rillettes de résout le
manque est finalement si ça vous a plu
au ciné c'est pas aimé la vidéo que je
le sache j'adore une fois faire des
petits jeux comme ça qui change vraiment
dur est quitte à ce qu'ils soient pas
fou fou folichon à on s'est compris
entre enquêteurs ou pas mais ça n'a rien
à se reprocher portez vous bien et puis
bonne semaine à l'étude le monde